[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation a couple of
announcements
one is the lights are going to stay up
because our speaker Rosabeth likes to
see what's going on with you and maybe
more interactive than some speakers also
Rosabeth has a new book America the
principled which there's some for sale
outside and she'll stick around for a
few minutes in the lobby after the talk
to sign some if you want that nice
announcement for long now there's
probably a fair number of long now
members here how many actually I thought
so great wind went through the
auditorium a long time fairly quiet but
significant supporter of long now has
been Pierre Omidyar and his wife Pam and
they are so focused on community as the
way things should happen in the world
that they like very much the way this
membership thing is going forward with
long now and they want to support it so
we're now announcing a matching grant of
two hundred thousand dollars from Pierre
and Pam for to match new memberships and
so people who become a member from now
through the end of June double your
money will happen to the foundation and
thank you and thank them this is coming
up on Christmas season and so people who
want to give gift memberships that I
gather is an option you members and
future members there's we had a event
for members with Brian you know a couple
months ago we'll have at least two more
events like that would be scheduled in
the next few months that will be just
for you years ago I was hired by royal
dutch/shell
AT&T and Volvo the senior people in
those three organizations who wanted to
think about organizational learning
and some new and productive ways and we
had a series of conferences that wound
up turning into the thing called global
business network that's now 20 years old
that I've been working at all that time
I was one of the cofounders but when I
first started looking at organizational
learning wasn't a hell of a lot of
literature on it but one who was very
good and as I got more and more into the
world of business and organizational and
governmental consulting I was the person
whose name and whose books kept coming
up again and again that's Rosabeth Moss
Kanter and that's why she's here tonight
ROS Beth thank you thank you Stuart
thank you I'm very honored to be
introduced by a legend so thank you for
that and hello to you in in San
Francisco it's a always a great pleasure
to be here I believe that my home city
of Boston and Cambridge is the only
other place in the country that has so
many visionary thinkers all in one place
well I'm here to talk to you about
long-term thinking enduring principles
for changing times and I'm known as a
guru of change but in fact I really hate
change I think change is a pain in the
neck change is what other people are
making me do you know that's why we
think about change whereas of course I
love being entrepreneurial creating new
projects that's not exactly change but
change has a bad reputation and that's
one of the reasons that I think we need
principles in order to cope with it and
I'll come back to that in a moment
but there's a story it was actually an
all-purpose commencement speech that was
written by one of my favorite management
philosophers Woody Allen
I see you've heard of him and it went
something like this
he said never before in human history as
humanity faced such a crossroads one
path leads to despair and utter
hopelessness the other road leads to
total oblivion
let us pray that we have the wisdom to
choose the right one well you know I'm
glad you laugh because actually in the
21st century this young 21st century
because of what's happened to the
national mood in fact what's happened to
the nation which is part of what
propelled me to write America the
principled I don't even think that's
particularly funny because sometimes
that seems like our choice every day in
fact I defined this as a gross national
comedy deficit when there are too many
people who have not long-term thinking
they have very short-term apocalyptic
thinking that the world's going to end
any minute anyway and so why bother
cleaning cleaning up the environment you
know why put in the effort well change
does have a bad reputation but that's in
part why we need enduring principles and
values because that's the only way that
we help people make sense of changing
times of the anxiety that we all feel
about what's being inflicted on us that
appears to make no sense one of the
things that leaders learn is that it's
more important to lead through rationale
understanding principles why we're doing
things than it is to simply issue
directives and so I did write America
the principled in order to provide a
coherent progressive agenda for seizing
our future and restoring what I think
our American strength Seneca
treat to be proud of with opportunity
for all by returning to enduring
principles we need enduring principles
and in fact in any effort to improve
things to make change to create a better
and brighter future we always hit
roadblocks and obstacles in the middle
in fact I defined this a long time ago
as Canter's law I'm not sure whether
anybody else calls it Cantor's love it
you can help me out
Cantor's law is that everything can look
like a failure in the middle
anything we start anything we start that
is new and different or is an attempt to
make an improvement upon current
practice always hits obstacles
roadblocks objections resistance to
change in the middle and that's a
problem of short-termism if you don't
have a goal of vision and underlying
principle and you hit that obstacle in
the middle every entrepreneur in the
room knows this that there were moments
when you had the naysayers and the
version that didn't work and the
problems and the team that defected and
the people who were hired away by your
competitor you stopped then and by
definition it's a failure but persist
persevere because of having an
underlying vision a set of principles
that say there's something that's going
to endure and we can make this work it's
often then a success and so long-term
thinking is incredibly important even to
the success of new ventures of new and
different things and so we need enduring
principles we need we need ways to make
sure that we don't panic in the middle
of things
that aren't quite working but instead we
persist because there's an underlying
set of values or an underlying set of
principles that were applying to that
effort whatever it is in fact in a my
last book called confidence how winning
streaks and losing streaks begin and end
I found that one of the reasons winning
streaks end that is success cycles end
is because people panic when something
unexpected happens and they immediately
drop all the values all the principles
that they stood for and I feel that that
has happened to our country in the 21st
century that a few assaults on America
and our sense of ourselves and suddenly
many people were willing to abandon
principles that we have stood for for
several centuries that have made this
the land of opportunity and I want to
get us back on track I want to get back
to the enduring principles that help us
cope with changing times if we lose
sight of those enduring principles then
we're going to be in trouble we'll panic
just like people panic in the midst of a
sports match and suddenly throw out the
game plan and can't succeed and I worry
that our country is in that position
right now and we have to get back to the
enduring principles that have always
made us strong and there are three that
I want to talk to you about talk with
you about tonight with lots of examples
of where I see these in place the first
principle enduring principle that helps
us cope with changing times is open
open minds I also happen to think we
need some other things to be more open
than they are but we certainly need open
minds a spirit of discovery human
perfectibility this is what has made the
country strong and this is what will
help us cope with changing times
in short innovation the mindset of an
innovator that's open to discovery where
a sense of progress and problem-solving
is built into everything we do and I
worry that in the last in the last years
of this century there has been an effort
to close minds rather than open it I
caught I talked about the kind of
thinking that we need for changing times
as kaleidoscope thinking we need to to
see the world the way a kaleidoscope
works when you look through a
kaleidoscope a set of a set of fragments
form a pattern but all we have to do is
twist it shake it change angle change
direction and suddenly the same
fragments form an entirely different
pattern it's often not reality that's
fixed it's our view of reality and often
the elements are already here if we're
willing to open our minds to new
possibilities human perfectibility is
one of those enduring principles that
has always made America strong we were
always the place of discovery not the
place of received wisdom but the place
where minds were open where we solved
problems where we did things in
different ways and that principle of
open minds of kaleidoscope thinking
has been lost in debates about science
versus religion in the United States for
example it's not really a debate between
science and religion its orthodoxy
versus creativity and I come down on the
end of creativity that's how we continue
to cope with changing times in Union
City New Jersey there was an incredible
experiment in changing education
dramatically that has made an enormous
difference and it's part of the
principle of opening minds to new
phenomena in Union City New Jersey one
of the failing schools in that community
a visionary mayor Robert Menendez who is
now a US citizen a US Senator Robert
Menendez partnered with the school
superintendent on the belief that even
the poorest urban kids out of poor
families in a failing school district
could learn and make a difference and
they sought partnerships with leading
technology companies to bring the best
and the latest to Union City because of
a belief that truly no child should be
left behind even though that legislation
is often mythical in its applications
and so in Union City New Jersey they
started on a journey of discovery a
journey of discoveries that would open
minds to the possibilities that the
children themselves could become the
teachers now that's an enduring American
phenomenon an enduring American
principle we were said to be the first
nation on earth in which in which the
young taught the old
well in Union City by applying new
technology and using the school as a
test site for the latest that Bell
Atlantic now Verizon wanted to offer
they not only gained experience with DSL
which is built into the product now they
put the children to work as teachers of
their parents and their teachers about
the technology and had an enormous gain
so I believe that the innovators of
America are there because we open minds
to discovery at the youngest ages and
must do more of that in order to have a
country which continues to move forward
I said the debate is not science versus
religion but orthodoxy versus creativity
values can constrain or values can
enable you know I had I taught a program
at Harvard that had senior executives
from the Middle East from nearly every
country in the Middle East except Israel
because the Israelis couldn't come to
that particular round of the program and
here was the most striking thing to me
about the program in terms of this issue
of Orthodoxy versus creativity not
science versus religion I taught a case
about Nelson Mandela the first
democratically elected president of
South Africa and an incredible role
model and a hero of how to bring a
country back from the brink of conflict
heal it and move it forward well I
taught the case about Mandela and his
philosophies and we're discussing the
case with the set of executives from the
Middle East and I was amazed at a
question they asked someone said well
what is Mandela's religion you don't
mention his religion so I asked the
if I said why is that important well
then we will know how he thinks well if
we know his religion we will know how he
thinks because I suddenly realized to
this group of leaders from Middle
Eastern countries with which America
supposedly today has a clash of
civilizations which i think is an
overstatement of a range of opinions and
views that are held in that region but
to them religion was received wisdom
religion then told you how to think and
I realized that in the traditions I grew
up in it was a starting point it wasn't
the answer but to them they said if we
don't know what his religion is we won't
know how to evaluate his leadership and
I thought how striking how different
from the principles that have made this
country great which are principles of
open minds of taking received wisdom
that has been handed down and doing
something to add to it
engage with it have a dialogue with it
and that is an enduring principle that
also produces change and that's really
what we're after in the United States we
are a place where we don't prejudge we
see the particular where we we don't
accept received wisdom we improve upon
it innovation has always been the thing
that has made this country great and so
the enduring principle even when times
change is that minds are open to
learning that the young can teach the
old that fresh knowledge can combine
with wisdom to make a difference and
that principle has made this country
strong and I argue that's an enduring
principle
that will help the rest of the world
cope with changing times once we restore
respect for the traditions of this
country the second the second enduring
principle for changing times is that
activities need to be directed toward a
higher purpose a sense of meaning in
fact I think we could be after an age of
30 year age of cynicism beginning to
enter an age of idealism if we shift the
political climate in America that the
sense of values or higher purpose as
creating meaning in life and meaning in
work meaning in all of our endeavors
even when even when times are changing
that's what indoors is the values and
sense of purpose that we start with
so if innovation is all about change
opening minds to new discoveries
engaging children as well as people of
all generations in a quest for the new
we also need a sense of higher purpose
that's an enduring principle and that's
also a principle that has long been part
of this country and is increasingly part
of the repertoire of a surprising set of
institutions we may be entering an era
of a new kind of capitalism we have the
potential to create a values-based
capitalism that puts a sense of purpose
to make a difference in the world at the
center of how businesses operate and how
businesses create social enterprises
that have a purpose even beyond making
money so let me give you an example of
that
IBM under Sam Palmisano has become a
strikingly different organization in the
21st century Palmisano inherited a
company that had been turned around by
Lou Gerstner and it was still among the
world's largest technology companies
depending on which products youlet
Packard overtook it in terms of certain
product lines but it's still one of the
world's Giants after it sold off some
efforts IBM was a little smaller but one
of Sam Palmisano first acts at IBM was
to convene a 300 / 300,000 purpose
person web chat called a values jam in
which every IBM er had an opportunity
over a three-day period to discuss
values to discuss what do we stand for
and why are we doing this work not to
talk about technology or strategy
although that came later when they also
convened an innovation Jam in which over
300,000 people weighed in on what should
be the technology priorities of the
future but he started of values jam a
kind of chat over a three-day period on
the web now IBM had a strong set of
values they thought they had been laid
down out of the head of Tom Watson in an
earlier period but Palmisano did it
differently in this open participative
process and in fact when he mentioned
this to the board of directors of IBM
one of the directors who had been CEO of
another large company in a fairly
conservative industry said to him this
is socialism and what sample Misano said
back as he said today we do need values
but they can no longer come from the
head of a CEO that sense we have
sophisticated people all over the world
they're cynical they speak different
languages they come out of different
cultural traditions unless they
participate in a conversation about what
we stand for what's our higher purpose
nobody's going to buy this nobody's
going to use it and so they had the web
chat they got all of this input they
distilled it down to a statement of
three key values at the centerpiece of
those values is a statement that says
innovation that makes a difference for
our customers and the world and that's
all the company needed to begin to begin
to operate in a very different way those
values are not just on a poster on paper
or on the web
those values are invoked all over the
world almost every day in meetings at
IBM and when I ask people why do there
seem to be so few political
disagreements there they say it's
because we have this statement of values
of course that tells us exactly what to
do
well it doesn't tell anybody what to do
it's very grand in general but it guides
activity by independent people and that
sense of higher purpose of a meaning
that transcends my own activity unites
IBM in a way that other organizations
are now starting to emulate and it it is
an enduring principle that we have
values and a sense of purpose that also
guides people in the work of change but
here's what pal Misano said about why he
did this and it's certainly long-term
thinking and it's best he said
management is temporary returns are
cyclical but if we use these values as
connective tissue that has longevity if
people can get emotionally connected and
have pride in the entity's success they
will do what is
important to IBM well defining that
sense of purpose so broadly innovation
that makes a difference for the world
was a license for people in the United
States to work differently when IBM had
a new technology for example IBM's
research labs had made major advances in
grid computing where you get the power
of supercomputers simply by harnessing
unused computing power from desktops
from PCs and they had made a major
advance in this and we're wondering how
they're gonna get this out of to the
marketplace and their customers and one
of the values keepers at IBM immediately
got wind of the technology is in Palma
Sano's office creating the model for
what they called world community grid
they gave away grid computing power
first before they started selling it
world community grid is a non-profit
established by IBM to get lots of us I
don't know if anybody here has their PC
running on world community grid you can
volunteer your unused computing power to
become part of this network because it
is then deployed on some of the world's
biggest and most challenging scientific
projects that need used amounts of
computing power and so you couldn't have
your computing power donated to projects
on hiv/aids cancer research heart
disease where just the number of images
require a great deal of computing power
in order to do the research and all over
the world certainly mostly in the US
where there's incredible pride in world
community grid but all over the world
I've been in executives offices where
they point to they point to the laptop
behind their desk and say oh today we're
processing data for a major Cancer
Research Project
well they gave it away first in a non
profit because of the values of the
sense of higher purpose and that's a new
kind of capitalism that's a new way of
approaching the world and we need more
of that in America we need to applaud
the people who are doing that we need to
see that being guided by principles and
values is provides more motivation for
employees
it helps partners to feel connected to
the company it makes new relationships
and it changes the world so a sense of
higher purpose is an enduring principle
that helps us change because if you have
a higher purpose then you know where
innovation should be directed and
targeted you don't hang on to orthodoxy
you become creative but you are
reinforcing that value and we need more
of that in America that's why I think
principles are behind how we should run
our country as well and a third enduring
principle and this is particularly an
American principle is common ground the
United States has been said to be the
first new nation by that political
scientists meant that it was the first
nation on earth defined not by race or
ethnicity or shared history but defined
by the fact that people were occupying
the same territory they were on common
ground in fact when people first started
settling the east coast of the United
States all of the towns were
characterized by having a commons in the
middle of the town where everybody would
come to graze their cattle where anybody
with a few exceptions when
couldn't vote and slaves still weren't
people so I can't say that everything
about American history was perfect and
inclusive but for the most part we had a
concept of standing on common ground and
that was what United us and that's a
principle that has been such an
important part of this country for all
the battles about waves of immigration
in fact gradually people started to
stand on common ground inclusion and
then the responsibilities of citizenship
have always been part of what this
country has stood for and in fact in the
1820s the French aristocrat Alexis de
Tocqueville came to the United States
and he wrote a famous book called
democracy in America and he didn't write
about our federal government he didn't
write about our big business what
because we didn't really have much of
course in his era but what he wrote
about was the ways in which Americans
who stood on common ground built
community because of voluntary actions
by citizens to take responsibility for
their own territory including all that
were in that territory and he said
Americans of all ages all stations of
life and all types of disposition are
forever forming associations in
democratic countries knowledge of how to
combine is the mother of all other forms
of knowledge on its progress depends
that of all the others in towns it is
impossible to prevent people from
assembling getting excited together and
forming sudden passionate resolves in
short we take responsibility ourselves
President Clinton declared that the era
of big government is over to be replaced
by the era of big citizens and that
enduring principle of citizen
responsibility is an opportunity to
infuse our country and the world with a
different sensibility and I have to say
this part of the country like mine my
home city of Boston
are the models for the nation in terms
of social entrepreneurs who form sudden
passionate resolves with their fellows
and not simply create new businesses but
create new nonprofits that become models
for the world and I think the donation
from pyramid yards the long now
foundation is a great example of the
generosity of Americans its generosity
that unites us its generosity that
unites us across partisan divides people
who can agree on the politics of a
situation often agree on the need to
help those in need and to create social
innovations that are going to produce a
better future its generosity that can
unite us and it's generosity that can
change the image of Americans in the
world this is a big problem and those of
you who do anything internationally here
whether it's in business or other realms
know that we must get back to those
principles because the view of America
in the world is very negative at the
moment in fact however there's a big gap
between the view of America the
government versus Americans the people
there's still much more goodwill around
the world to Americans than there is to
our country in part because of a losing
streak of a war in Iraq as
well as other actions that never didn't
really make their countries safer or
better as we see in the situation in
Pakistan in its neighbor Afghanistan at
the moment however we can restore that
view of the world if we again return to
that enduring principle of common ground
through service where responsibility is
taken by citizens we can mobilize
citizen diplomats who are already
involved in projects in Africa in
projects in the Middle East because of
the generosity of Americans and our
penchant to form nonprofits voluntary
associations at the grassroots and do it
ourselves we have an opportunity to do
things that the government cannot do and
of course is not doing the defense
budget is a is about 23 percent of the
federal budget when my research staff
and I were counting up how much of the
federal budget was spent on programs
involving any kind of diplomacy or aid
that came to less than 1/16
of 1% of the entire budget well that gap
is being made up by us that we the
people through our desire to unite on
common ground to take responsibility at
the grassroots all over the world
because of the Gates Foundation's
efforts and contributions as private
philanthropy 22 governments were
encouraged to get involved in childhood
immunizations it's often our voluntary
actions out of the private sector the
galvanize government into doing things
so I think service is sorely needed in
the United States and I'm a gigantic
advocate of national
servus civilian national service I'm on
the board and helped with the founding
of a Youth Service Corps it's active in
San Jose it's a national core it was the
model for AmeriCorps President Clinton's
National Service Program it's called
City Year and young people 17 to 24 have
the opportunity to sign up for a year of
full-time service and when they do that
they are deployed in schools they're
deployed in community organizations they
make a difference in the community but
they also become united as a force
across diverse aspects of the population
they reach out across partisan divides
to various members of the community and
they create a new sense of what the
Commons the common ground can be the
first President Bush had created the
points of light foundation in order to
get more volunteerism in America and I
looked at that and said who could be
against it
a thousand points of light the more
lights the better I say but if those
lights are not focused like a laser beam
on some of our most difficult problems
we will not be the country in the future
in changing times that I want us to be
so national service as an effort that we
should ask every presidential candidate
to endorse national service is one of
those ways that we can take disparate
efforts and through full time cores of
young people full-time cores of retiring
baby boomers who are part of experienced
Corps which civic ventures right here in
San Francisco has created we can create
a force that can not only bring about
change in the
world but can help us change in America
solve some of our most difficult
problems while bringing us together on
common ground and that's the spirit i
won in america and those three
principles open minds open minds in
which we can learn from the young as
well as from those who are more senior
than we are a world of discovery of
innovation in which we don't get bogged
down in orthodoxy which kind of science
is allowed to be taught in the schools
for example a world of higher purpose
and higher higher aspirations in which
our businesses are run by values and not
by bureaucracy or control systems or
putting money first but rather getting
to higher purposes that can make a
difference in the world and in which we
find common ground that those kinds of
enduring principles can help us cope
with some of the most difficult problems
we have in America because we have
models of how to make each of these
things work and this 21st century that I
says have a gross national comedy
deficit and where any way we change
seems like it's going to bring troubles
like my Woody Allen story this kind of
America has been living through
something we know better on the East
Coast than you do here but endless
winter you know Shakespeare in one of
his tragedies had a famous line now is
the winter of our discontent and I feel
that we've been in a endless winter of
discontent in the 21st century because
winter is a time where we don't open our
minds we closed our doors winter is a
time when we huddle in fear don't want
to go out on the streets it's too cold
rather than remember the
purposes that we stand for winter is a
time when people retreat rather than
stand on common ground well if this has
been the winter of our discontent then I
think we need a shift of seasons now the
former governor of California President
Reagan coasted to the presidency in the
1980s when he said ok it's morning in
America and I say let's make it summer
in America year-round because the spirit
of summer is the spirit that reflects
openness and a sense of energy that
means that higher purposes can be
obtained and standing on common ground
in summer people come out from behind
closed doors they go out on the street
they think they can fix their
communities in summer people go back to
nature we become we become closer to the
thing the to our origins we simplify in
summer class distinctions tend to be
erased because we all dress the same in
summer we trust strangers the new
Commons in America instead of the places
where we grazed cattle in New England
centuries ago the new Commons in America
might be the public beach because on
public beaches there are studies that
actually confirm this people will leave
their belongings in the sight of
strangers and yet wander off in complete
trust that spirit of summer should be
translated into a summer of service for
middle school people middle school
children to a spirit of optimism
openness higher purpose generosity and
common ground those enduring principles
and the spirit of
summer can bring us back to what we've
always stood for but had forgotten which
is the land of opportunity one of the
most respected nations on earth a beacon
for democracy the source of innovation
that's where I'd like us to be in the
future and those are enduring principles
that even in these troubled difficult
times that sometimes do feel like
endless winters until we have a
presidential election and maybe shift to
summer that's the America I'd like to
see in the future using open minds a
sense of higher purpose in every
endeavor and standing on common ground
thank you and I look forward to dialogue
with you
you talked about the national level a
lot and a little bit about an
institutional level like IBM and also
principles or something that individuals
often operate on what's different what's
the same at those different levels um
first of all I think principle base
management principle based leadership
principles that we operate by in our
life what's the same about them as
principles our enduring principles are a
rationale they tell us why they come
from values they tell us something about
the goal we want to get to they are they
endure even as we hit obstacles and
roadblocks they become so important that
we don't let them go at every system
level but what's different I mean at the
national level at the national level we
often count on leaders to articulate
them or not and we have had leaders that
have not particularly stood on principle
first of all they've often had not only
have they had ad-hoc responses to
situations they have justified actions
based not on principles but on fear
seized and consolidated power because
they said we know better by withholding
information so at the national level
we're very dependent on leaders because
they control institutions that allow us
to be free or not several questions here
said will George Bush has principles we
just don't like the problem that they're
just different principles well I think
they're not these kinds of principles
that's why I articulated several
principles they're not open minds
principles because he stood against
science time and again not letting
empirical truths findings learning
knowledge open minds to new
possibilities but instead closing minds
by saying I know best
I speak directly to God
and there are certain things that we
simply will rule out California has been
a pioneer for example in saying well if
the federal government is banning
stem-cell research we'll do it here and
by the way in America the principled I
point out that the so-called when our
current targeted enemy part of the axis
of evil Iran which is led by religious
fundamentalists has stem-cell research
so that's a quite that's an irony so so
there are some principles that close and
there are principles that open and so
what we have to do is stand for
principles or values that open minds
that open possibilities that include
rather than exclude I can see up several
the questions refer this and regard the
Bushmen regard to various things which
is part of how principle works and the
wholesome way you're speaking about is
it's pretty deep it's you know it's it's
right down there and root and when a
principle is not working out or a whole
lot of people let you know by voting or
whatever that they're really not that
enchanted with your principle how does
principle itself deal with change well
first of all I tried to define three
principles that are change oriented by
definition that is open minds is a
principle that lets you learn new things
higher purpose is a principle that says
I have a responsibility or an obligation
to use our technology the resources of
our company to make sure they're
directed toward solving problems that
matter for people in the world and the
third principle common ground is one
that talks about inclusion plus the
responsibilities of citizenship so those
are all principles that tend to permit
change therefore they're good for
changing times and there are countries
in the world
that have cultures and have principles
that actually close off possibilities
when I was teaching a program at Harvard
for those Middle Eastern executives it
and they wanted to know about Mandela's
religion the reason they wanted to know
of course is because they said every
because then will know what he's going
to do next because it was all given back
then so those that's a principle and I
respect people's faith but that's a
principle that doesn't open you to
learning what else surprise to you in
that session you did with middle eastern
folks well several things surprised me
first of all when I teach my case on
Nelson Mandela two Harvard MBAs and you
know Harvard MBAs are a kind of arrogant
Bunch
and there's never any of any one of my
former students here you'll remember
anyway so there when Harvard MBAs do
case studies discussions of case studies
of the most famous CEOs and political
leaders in the world they've never met a
CEO they can't improve on but Nelson
Mandela was held in such high esteem
that my MBAs when I asked them my
typical opening question which is so are
there things he could have done to be
more effective they're silent when I
asked that question to the executives
from the Middle East they immediately
had several things to improve upon in
Mandela and the major one was he was not
tough enough on his enemies and I
immediately felt I understood a great
deal more of the culture that has led
some people to say there's a clash of
civilizations I happen to think that
kind of dualistic thinking you know
you're for us are you against us is the
wrong kind of thinking for our times I
think actually and I talked about in the
book
the change agent rule of thirds which is
in any situation yes there are your
allies there your opponents but there's
a vast group in the middle that you
reach but these but this particular
group wanted him not to include and
forgive and find common ground they
wanted him to be really hard to
retaliate hard on those who had
oppressed his people they wanted revenge
and revenge is not a motive that builds
a productive future you know revenge
might feel good at a particular moment
but it doesn't move you forward in a
positive and progressive way so you're
close student and teacher of Nelson
Mandela and the reconciliation process
they did in South Africa where have
you've seen that being picked up
elsewhere in the world I don't really
see it being picked up often enough but
I do see it being picked up in essence
in some companies by enlightened chief
executives who want to have an open
dialogue about what were the mistakes of
the past and we're not going to punish
anybody for it because if you're not
able I suppose we could call this
another enduring principle and it has to
do with that organizational learning by
which you introduced me but that if
you're not able to learn from past
experience you can't improve upon it and
if you can't talk about it because
you're going to be punished so severely
you can't move on either and so
countries get stuck on this quest for
revenge and I don't really see except in
smaller institutions the open dialogue
that's required in a non punitive way to
find common ground and move forward
here's a global question from Kevin
Kelley is what's good for America good
for China would you expect the same
three principles to thrive in China our
open minds higher purpose and common
volunteerism Universal I think that's a
really great question and the answer is
not yet but very possible
we keep hearing you know countries are
different but there are some universal
human desires to have voice even in
systems where things there's much more
respect for hierarchy and elders and and
tradition still people like having voice
and I think that as the technology makes
it more possible I think that China we
see today could be very different
there already is discontent in some of
the provinces among the peasants and so
forth that challenge a central
government that tries to have all wisdom
and then the businesses in China are
increasingly interacting with the world
and being influenced by how we do things
and I don't think these are American
values I think they're human values but
I teach executives from China at Harvard
and I think if we look for what those
commonalities are and I don't want to
keep coming back to the global
corporation except that I think I am
working right now on I have an article
coming out in Harvard Business Review in
January called transforming Giants and I
think some of these companies like IBM
and Procter and Gamble and a few from
other parts of the world
Omron and Japan semak's and Mexico and
so forth are producing a different model
and they've already had to struggle with
the question of universality of values
for example some rights that we now take
for granted in the United States in this
part of the United States I should say
not quite in the rest of the United
States gay and lesbian rights for
example well it's that's illegal in
Egypt and IBM has had to struggle with
how we take this respect for people and
their differences and managed to still
act on it even in a country where you
can't really talk about it they'd be
specific about that
what how they do it well again the value
and these aren't just words on paper but
the value of respect and inclusion to
respect who people are and listen to
them for their expertise rather than for
the package they come in has been taught
to people and there are people are in
not just training programs but are
encouraged to be mentors to look after
people to make sure that those values
are being acted on and so while for
example there are huge tensions between
Egypt and Israel political tensions
religious tensions cultural tensions
finding common ground on a technical
problem has meant that the cairo
development lab works with a high
fidelity a speak a common language so by
stressing a value respect and inclusion
by creating problems that transcend how
we're different that's why i like
national service for building common
ground we're not going to have a great
dialogue across races across partisan
lines and but if we put people together
with a task and a deadline they will
begin to work together and then the
third is common language common
vocabulary common tools so you're giving
people the infrastructure to be able to
work together I mean this is one of my
hopes by the way for all the technology
that still this is the capital of the
world in producing that it's going to
make it easier for us to join because
it's also going to preserve the identity
and the languages and the culture of
very small groups because that can stay
alive on the web too but meanwhile we
have some things that unite us and so as
interaction increases between countries
back to the China question as people
have to do business across boundaries as
Chinese enterprises state-owned or not
realize that they have consumed
now they're not just the government but
they have consumers all over the world
who might not like it if they are
pillagers of the earth in Africa because
of how they're extracting the oil
they're not gonna like it that starts
changing behavior couple questions
relating to national service and I've
got some too one strong one comes from
John Gilmore right here why should we do
national service when the nation is one
of our biggest problems rather than
serving the corrupt government goals
let's serve our communities our
principles or the whole world fantastic
way of putting it you know I may be so
close to the national service movement
that the word national doesn't really
bother me but we're civilian national
services really community service that's
where we deploy people and when I talked
about citizen diplomats and philanthropy
and generous people the Oprah Winfrey
Leadership School for girls or clean
water which Procter and Gamble has been
working on in Africa that's all at the
grassroots and I totally agree what
national civilian national service
really means is community service which
also has that other connotation of you
were forced to do it in lieu of prison
so we don't like that connotation maybe
we need a different word for all of this
but in fact the proposal there are
proposals on the table now not only for
a summer of service for eighth graders
who are too young to work but have a lot
of energy and could do a lot of good but
there are proposals on the table for a
whole range of very targeted service
corps like Teach for America writ large
so we have an education Corps we might
have a health care Corps which is
designed to fill in the gaps get
childhood immunization in every
neighborhood and also help teach the
young people or the older people who
were there enough about health care that
they're better prepared to go on to be
professionals in those fields so there's
a range of proposals that are targeted
but all of the services deployed at
local levels and as far as City Year
goes that's extremely local in that the
model the funding model is only forty
percent of the money comes from the
federal government from AmeriCorps the
rest comes from private contributions
and which also brings the private sector
into the idea of service and the chance
to participate along with the young
people and it comes from mayors and
governors who think this is really good
for their community and in fact in
around 2003 when Congress tried to kill
national service by reducing the funding
dramatically because the Republicans who
are supposedly all in favor of
volunteerism didn't like the idea what
you're paying volunteers well they
didn't get it that the thousand points
of light needs the laser beam so voices
for AmeriCorps was started and
immediately seventy two members of the
Senate and this is when that was a lot
of Republicans to anybody who had a
program in their state really loved it
and practically every governor and lots
of Mayors all plus lots of private
citizens rose up to say this is one of
the best things we can do in fact if
there's one thing that could transform
our country quickly it would be to
everybody feeling of responsibility and
having the opportunity to serve part
time full time over a year over more
years organized in a way that has impact
and we don't really quite have that yet
in fact after 911 a tremendous
opportunity to call Americans to service
well I don't want to say we because I
had nothing to do with that
administration in Washington but that
opportunity was lost on the part of our
leaders who never said now's our time
where we all want to give something to
strengthen our country imagine if we had
a civil defense core and forget that the
word defense sounds like the military
civil defense core that when there's a
disaster or an emergency knows exactly
what to do in every neighborhood and
that might be part-time and volunteers
we do have that here Community Emergency
Response Teams and neighborhood here's a
lot of volunteer people will then send
for this is great model yeah my wife and
I both joined that right after 9/11 that
was you know our response but we were to
ask to that I'm sure most of your
opinion on national service I was lucky
enough to instead of going to graduate
school I did two years in the Army it
was better graduate school than any I
could have taken from my standpoint and
all of us know people how many Peace
Corps people are here by any chance
thank you for your service people have
been in the Peace Corps the most
transformed people I know yes and yet
and yet I was a volunteer in the army
Peace Corps people are volunteers there
are older ones now as well as young ones
as you know and in Vietnam we had a
draft army and it had serious problems
in Iraq we have a volunteer army and I
can tell you as a close critic of how
military behaves we have a better army
because it's volunteer so how does that
map with universal service and the
question of choice and volunteerism how
do they mix right well first of all I'm
not sure I said Universal required okay
just want bigger more and that's a good
starting point because we have something
that works so well and does so much good
and is so small in numbers even the
Peace Corps is a very small number of
people and we need many more people
along a continuum of service some will
be for a summer some will be for long
periods of time some will become
professionals at it and organize it for
others but we I know that we just need
more of it whether it becomes a
requirement I think there are other ways
that change occurs and one is that other
people are doing it and therefore young
people think this is a really
cool and wonderful thing to do and there
are other kinds of incentives which
involve things like the kind of training
you're going to get because of this
Teach for America right now is a small
program and yet there is Wendy Kopp
everywhere Teach for America may have
six or seven thousand in their teacher
Corps now that's all given the vast size
of public education and it has so much
visibility but it was has been the
number one recruitment choice on college
campuses for major colleges something
like eleven percent of all graduates of
Notre Dame last year applied for Teach
for America I mean there's an amazing
hunger on the part of the population to
find these opportunities and this is
different from chequebook charity
although that's good but that doesn't
necessarily build community we need
people actively working to and we have
not provided enough opportunities so I
think we could expand it dramatically
without requiring it and then it becomes
the cool thing to do you know one of her
let me say something on another point I
didn't make earlier because these
inner-city schools like the one in Union
City New Jersey which happened to be 92
percent Hispanic when they mobilized the
kids to learn about technology and and
now they're all wanting to be scientists
they're going to college well there are
many many places where there's more
talent than we're pop than than we're
using at all and this is a way to start
getting people out of various places
right now in inner-city neighborhoods
being smart and studying and doing well
in school is called acting white and we
have a million school dropouts high
school dropouts in America I'm a million
it's a number that we could even
envision a campaign to say we're gonna
reduce that to a thousand you know we'll
leave the residual
but we could do something about that but
we don't yet have the means to organize
enough people and it does cost something
so you know when the Republicans say
well I don't want to pay volunteers I
mean somebody has to help do the
organizing here's a question of someone
speaking that from Laura Walter right
here in our rapidly changing high tech
culture youth teaching us all seems a
given but how do we balance this and
raise the marginalized voice of aged
wisdom and experience in our society or
another way to put it is will the baby
boomers do this for us Laura is clearly
looking for it from both sides please I
think that's a really great question
because it does say something about
America where we get a little excessive
I mean Margaret Mead said about America
that we were well she had a technical
word for it she called it I well a post
figurative culture but she said we were
the only culture she could find in which
the untaught the old and every other
culture wisdom of experience meant
something but she should know about that
she didn't like that
well that was bad for continuity yeah
and it's innate well but it also was a
given with a nature a nation of
immigrants that the kids often learn
things before the parents did the
language or the latest knowledge and we
took that to excess excuse me for
anybody who was involved in that in the
dot-com boom of the 90s where big
companies that had been very successful
for years turned turned over huge new
ventures to 23 year olds with ponytails
purple hair you know the we all remember
that and some of them were really good I
will say but there was a lot that got
lost in that process and I wrote about
that in an earlier book called evolve
because there were mistakes made because
it wasn't married the company suddenly
here's something so new none of us know
anything about it so they threw out what
they did know things about which may be
how to make money in a business not just
collect money from the capital markets
you know there were a lot of mistakes
that were made in that era and so then
we shifted I saw many of those same
companies not one anybody young anymore
they only wanted seasoned executives and
it's a little bit like Eric Schmidt
coming into Google now that happens to
be a great marriage and I think that's
the kind of marriage we need between
people who have seen it all or seen a
lot and people who are willing to
challenge convention and have the latest
knowledge and if we can marry those we
have almost the perfect leadership
structure and I think with the boomers
now becoming such a huge force having
twenty to thirty more productive years
of life and knowing that they once
changed the world I think they're gonna
do it again and and I think that they're
gonna insist on a different a different
kind of respect and what we need is a
marriage of wisdom and fresh thinking
and I don't think all the fresh thinking
necessarily comes from the young and I
don't think all the wisdom necessarily
comes from people just because they've
been doing something for a long period
of time we have not figured out how to
value experience in America because we
discard things and I think easily we
discard them and we forget you know I
have a great career out on the corporate
circuit because the length of a manager
g real generous about three or two four
years so then there's a whole new set of
people and i can come again and say the
same thing i said you know three or four
years ago that's that's a great business
model so that is something that i think
the sheer weight of the demographics
will start to change well you watch
students go through harvard and now
you're it sounds like you're watching
these managers go through these
organizations that are going back to do
you see any sort of trends over time and
though
student bodies well I think that do I
see trends in the because well I see I
see people in the MBA program and we've
and and some of it is what we select for
and one of my colleagues has just
written a great book trashing business
education but he and I are very close
colleagues and and we agree on this I
think in a lot of ways what what has
been taught to earlier generation of
managers has not necessarily led
businesses in the right direction so
we're trying to correct that we now
select for leadership and leadership
potential and so we do get a different
kind of person and what I see is an
enormous amount of let me call it
idealism or concern about values and
principles and a desire at some point in
life to create a social enterprise or a
nonprofit that makes a big difference
but meanwhile I'll pay off my student
loans and make a lot of money I mean the
sense of values and again it may be our
selection criteria but the sense of
values in this generation I think has
been underreported at least on the part
of those who see themselves as leaders
and many now come for an MBA already
having not only started enterprises
because in the dot-com boom you could do
it when you were in college and Facebook
started that way and so forth even today
but they already have started nonprofits
and they've already been around the
world doing service in Africa or Latin
America should they push back when you
get up and lecture them well I don't
lecture them ok so when you do would I
know how would I dare but well I mean
that's not our teaching method which is
also one of these principles finding
common grounds opening minds etc our
teaching method is all discussion and I
sort of have to sneak it in by
indirection but the answer is no I don't
have a problem personally because I'm
established and they want to learn from
me and I think there is a lot of mutual
respect as long as I respect them
so these generational problems we talked
about have to do with the same kind of
polarizing thinking I talked about
earlier with clashes of civilizations
and dualistic thinking that you know the
you we talked about this before the
program that there are some
organizations a generation saying well
we're ready to do nothing and have
leisure and let those young people work
to pay our Social Security that's how
they view it we're talking it's a little
generational politics here this was a
discussion I was having earlier about
the AARP which in my view is the most
powerful lobby in Washington and it is
all about the obligations of the youth
the old and my complaint to them is I
think AARP should at least partly be
about the obligations that the old to
the young yeah I mean and we do have
some generation absolutely and we do
have some generational politics because
there are communities that banned
children no senior Grand resort living
communities banned children there are
there are places in which people won't
vote for school levies because you know
they don't have children what do they
care so it's that same though kind of
spirit of selfishness in the winter of
our discontent where we're less generous
and it's every person for themselves and
where everyone is a potential enemy
that's what I want to get rid of if we
can find that common ground and often it
is through some physical service where
people have come together to do
something and they get to know each
other okay last question this one from
Kevin Kelly are some higher purposes
higher than others does the particular
purpose matter or does it just have to
be higher than an individual you know
what if your higher purpose is to save
souls go for it I mean I does it have to
be are there some better than others the
whole spirit of openness
and and shall I daresay liberalism that
pervades that what I've talked about
tolerance inclusion says that I can't
prejudge purpose one purpose is better
than another I do know however if that
starts to intrude upon the rights of
other people to express theirs then I'd
be concerned about it but but otherwise
not we are in America our sense of
purpose is often expressed religiously
it's also expressed secularly and we are
simultaneously de Tocqueville said this
about us he said we were the most
materialistic and at the same time the
most spiritual and devout he said we
were the so individualistic and yet we
were communitarian there's a lot of
contradictions in a country like ours do
I think some purposes are better than
others well you know that's the voice of
the people people will I don't want
purpose I I mean there are certain
values that we do say we should hold in
common and I think respect and tolerance
or that but we need we need dialogues
about that there some people don't
believe that there's some people who
think that they should they should
exclude so what I really want is the
process the open mind process of
learning of engaging with one another of
finding common ground where we have a
task we want to accomplish together and
that tends to reduce the acrimony or the
divisive nasai a
disagree and I'm willing to have
anybody's faith or vision subject to the
marketplace of ideas as long as there's
sufficient information and education
that people can make informed choices I
wouldn't do that if it's demagoguery and
no counter information that's why I like
the Free Press such as its remnants are
so much and why I think the internet for
all that we
there's misinformation and there's no
editing process but you know the wisdom
of crowds does have a lot going for in
that sense being small D Democrats and
doing what Sam Palmisano did I mean I
keep repeating that because it is so
amazing to have over 300,000 people in a
business where there's supposedly
Authority still be asked to weigh in and
be given the opportunity to participate
and the technology will make it possible
to let that marketplace of ideas survive
it'll also make it possible for small
niche groups to survive at the same time
that we find some common conversation we
can all have sounds good thank you thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]